- Selon les contrôleurs routiers
camion a une vision très limitée
de son entourage, en raison de
ce que l'on appelle les angles
morts. Nous avons eu l'occasion
de monter à bord de ce poide
sensibilisation portant
justement sur les angles morts.
MARIE-JOSÉE MICHAUD, agente
contrôle routier, SAAQ.
où sont ces angles morts-là,
ni leur dimension, ce qui est
inquiétant.
- Voici donc les fameux angles
c'est en rouge sur cette
maquette, et on le voit,
c'est beaucoup plus grand que
l'on pense.
le conducteur ne voit pas,
par exemple, cette à
l'avant du camion, ni ce
cycliste sur le coté.
prêtés à l'exercice.
- En avant de vous, présentement
du véhicule là, il y a
une poussette pour enfant.
Là, vous ne la voyez pas.
Vous ne voyez pas le véhicule
qui est à votre gauche.
Imaginez un cycliste,
un piétoc'est la rentrée scolai.
- Et c'est le coté avant droit
du camion qui est le moins
Alors, voici un conseil
précieux.
- Est-ce que je vois les yeux du
les voyez, vous êtes au bon
endroit,e les voyez
pas, vous êtes en danger dans
son angle mort et vous devez
sécurité.
- Selon la Société de
l'assurance automobile,
impliqués dans 23 % des
accidents mortels avec piéto
et 28 % des accidents mortels
avec cyclistes.
maintenant, selon le SPVM,
il y a eu, l'an dernier,rnier,r,
huit personnes qui ont été tuées
dans une collision impliquant
La SAAQ formule également
deux autls : Portez
attention aux clignotants des
véhicules aux intersections etsn
portant des vêtements voyants.
Ici Jac Radio-Canada, Mon